ah oui un coup de gueule de francesca
oui alors quel est votre coup de gueule
française dont on va rappeler ce qui
s'est passé un jardin qui est dans sa
candidate de la star academy numéro 2 a
lâché bon en début de semaine en disant
clairement que tout ça était totalement
truquée et que tout était prévu d'
avance alors on avait de temps on avait
temporisé sur le plateau avec avec cyril
jamais expliqué un petit peu les aider
les archanges de la manipulation des
votes possible qu'en pensez vous ma
chère
francesca ça m'agace profondément
pourquoi parce que les mots ont un sens
il a dit truqués il n'a pas dit orienté
depuis l'hérault
oui m'enfin de truquer cc c'est très dur
comme mot surtout que star académie
c'est une des rares émissions dites de
télé réalité qui bénéficie d'une belle
image
on a tous un bon souvenir de star
académie et nous enfin moi qui ai
participé c'est important pour moi aussi
qu'on dise que c'était une belle
émission que voilà qu'on s'est pas foutu
de notre gueule qu'on a vécu des bons
belle aventure que c'était pas putassier
et que c'était pas truqué c'est
important alors effectivement à chaque
fois à chaque semaine quand on devait
chanter il y avait des petits reportages
avant et il pouvait être un petit peu
orienté mais c'est pas du trucage c'est
simplement le cas dans toutes les
émissions où il ya justement des petits
portraits sur les candidats donc moi ça
m'énerve qu'on veuille faire du buzz des
années après en plus c'est un mec sympa
georges-alain donc je vois pas ce qui
lui est passé dans la tête
à part se faire un petit peu de buzz
c'est bon là je la sphère crache pas
dans la soupe
c'est un truc franchement c'est comme
s'ils ont craché sur ma famille sarah
que sam se reprendre dans quelques
années
ben je venais sur un plateau de gizeh
way they pmp franchement c'est de la
merde et j'apprécierai enfin je
comprendrais qu'ils en aient qu'il le
prenne vraiment très mal alors la star
ac c'est sacré dont parle d'autre chose
genre alors nous avons nous avons la
réponse de georges alain en exclusivité
wii qui a répondu à ce qu'on a dit sur
ce plateau elle sert il écoutons le
[Musique]
à ce stade là de l'émission j'étais avec
lui j'étais abattu alors en gros pour
résumer à temps il n'est pas dit que
c'est plutôt à ranger
il ya aussi aujourd'hui je pense une
guerre d'intérêts de la part de beaucoup
d'anciens candidats puisque cet été va y
avoir une tournée dans cinq ans darracq
alors on n'a pas joué beaucoup et vous
en faites partie
oui déjà entendu dire du mal des stades
en jeu mais je jamais c'est un peu
inquiétant c'est bon on va chanter du
coup
[Applaudissements]
on est un peu au créneau pour défendre
quelques intérêts qui sera comme koh
lanta rien encore vous savez pas vous
mettre des gens qui chante sur scène
c'est ça oui très bien super et c'était
ça donne envie d'une tournée on a bâti à
mettre tout nu et pays dans ses comptes
avec des vaches n est pas ça m'attriste
beaucoup mieux